Шановні колеги Шкода що так мало
депутатів в залі бо головна завдання
нашої Верховної Ради є виконання трьох
речей перше - це законодавче
забезпечення нашої Перемоги друге
Парламентська дипломатія третя або може
перше Це допомога армії і саме про це Я
сьогодні хотів би переговорити
вчора Ранком я повернувся з лінії фронту
мав можливість поспілкуватися з
командирами Бригади батальйонів Хочу
наголосити що питання можливості бригад
мати доступ до ресурсів місцевих
бюджетів є принципово важливо
швидко і ефективно вирішувати ці
проблеми і на жаль Вчора ми
проголосували
ви проголосували
2006 голосами забрати ці гроші у
місцевого самоврядування забрати їх у
військових і передати їх на якісь
ефемерні програми де краще знають де
купляти яйця по 17 де купляти куртки за
тройною ціною і Як роздавати на початку
широкомасштабної агресії величезну
кількість попередньої оплати
я прошу до другого читання спільно
зібратися робочої групи
сконцентрувати ці гроші виключно на
забезпечені бригад з пунктів постійної
дислокації забезпечити ефективний
контроль за цими грошима і захистити
місцеве самоврядування і децентралізація
і друга позиція позиція учасників
бойових дій немає Зараз нічого важливого
важливішого ніж захистити наших воїнів У
нас знову законопроект Про убд стоїть в
кінці
законопроект мого авторства взагалі
навіть не розглянутий комітетом і я
наголошую що треба не принижувати наших
воїнів а вести питання про
справедливість бо їм ці ксіви не
потрібні це наше з вами зобов'язання
дати їм законодавчі і захист щоб вони
могли захистити членів своїх родин
захистити родини загиблих і сьогодні
розглянути цей законопроект не плутаючи
його з формуванням різних реєстрів
намаганням підтягнути туди полегшення
проведення виборів бо мета сьогодні
України - це перемога в війні проти
Путіна і проти Росії а не перемога на
виборах як дехто намагається кожен
законопроект тут використати вимагаємо
розглянути убд вимагаємо сформувати
робочу групу по
законопроекту ПДФО залишити захистити
воїнів і місцеве самоврядування Слава
Україні